I'm about to teach you a rarely used
method that I use to grow my Audience by
5 million people in under 24 months and
the crazy thing is is 24 months ago I
had less than 10 000 followers and I
knew nothing about YouTube Tick Tock
Instagram Twitter or any of these other
platforms and the reason that I was able
to catapult to you know a top one
percent Creator in that 24 month period
is using this method that for some
reason no one really talks about
whenever I enter a new space whether
it's trying to learn a new skill a new
platform a new anything I realized
there's a massive amount of skill
deficiency that I have to overcome as
fast assembly possible and so I can
either deploy time or I can deploy money
to save myself time so within the world
of organic content I was like who can I
pay to shortcut my path to getting to
where they are so on one hand I could go
to like celebrities and I did go to some
of them and they would give me their
strategies but it was like very
personalized and tailored to them and I
didn't think it would apply to like how
I run acquisition.com in my daily life
on the other hand there was like the
coaches gurus Etc that I could go to and
I didn't want to do that because they
might be using something that worked
like five years ago which honestly I see
all the time they're like guys you've
got to do hashtags on YouTube videos I'm
like what are you talking about like
this that's that's not true and the
third option which I ultimately went
with are advertising agencies and what
an agency is is just a business that
sells Services of advertising on your
behalf I can pay someone to run ads for
me I can pay someone to cut edit and
distribute content on my behalf so what
I want to do is help you decide whether
or not you should use an agency and
avoid what I call the agency trap
there's different tiers of agencies
there's the guys who just make stuff and
then there's the people who are real
pros contextually here for one brand on
one platform a small one might cost
three-ish maybe five thousand a month
the more advanced ones are usually in
the 15 to 30 000 a month so it's
significantly more money so here's how I
use agencies now and how you can too
phase one is I get what I would consider
a basic agency so long from getting into
YouTube the first step I didn't was I
hired three to five thousand dollar a
month agency and they just got me to
commit to doing three videos a week they
just trimmed it which means you take out
the oohs and Oz put an intro and a
thumbnail the main objective of that
first phase was just to get the basics
down forcing me to create content on a
regular cadence once I have more context
because I spent three six months working
with them seeing what the audience likes
then I'm like okay now I want to learn
everything so I go from beginner of
learning the basics and doing the
fundamentals to how do the top creators
create on this platform no business
owner should change their business for
one client and so it makes sense for
both me and the small agency or for you
in a small agency to part ways at some
point when your demands for what you
want exceed their capacity so then I
work with the much better more advanced
agency who works with the top creators
to learn all of the more nuanced pieces
of the platform so rather than agree to
their initial terms which is basically
pay us as long as humanly possible and
we hope you pay until you die this is
exactly what I say gather round
I want to do what you do in my business
but I don't know how I'd like to work
with you for six months so I can learn
how you do it plus I'll pay extra for
you to break down why you make the
decisions you do and the steps you take
to make them then after I get a good
idea of how it all works I'll start
training my team on it and once they can
do it well enough I'd like to change to
a lower cost Consulting agreement this
way you can still help us if we run into
problems are you opposed to this when
you start that way I like it because
you're starting with very clear
intentions and you're saying hey I'm
going to commit to six months this is
what I want from you and I'm also saying
I'm going to continue to pay you after
the engagement's over for a much higher
leverage much more profitable Consulting
engagement so that's what a lot of
agencies would ultimately want and if I
need to pay a little bit more than the
agency fee up front then I'm willing to
do that I also understand that as I
start to train my team on internally
there will be a period of time where I'm
paying both them and my team so you're
paying twice the thing is is that when
you do that you're actually building the
Enterprise value of your business and
you're building the asset that you own
rather than being reliant on somebody
else who eventually could if you wanted
to
cut you off and then you'd be dead in
the water or what more realistically
happens is they gouge you and they
continue to raise the price because they
can see how much money you're making
from the thing with that new agency we
ran the same play hey we want to learn
from you we want to understand why
you're picking these things we want to
understand the decision making process
Etc I start documenting what they're
doing into our processes internally we
want to start co-creating so they're
making stuff for us and we're making
stuff for us and eventually our stuff
for us starts to be as good and
eventually better than the stuff that
they make for us and it should be
because I'm only one client of many to
them and I'm basically renting them as
fractional labor with expertise at a
premium once your team has the same
amount of expertise or more they should
be better because one they have more
time because they're going to fully
allocate their time to you and secondly
because they will always have more
context on your brand than an agent will
by having more time and more context all
we have to fill is the gap of expertise
and so once we have the expertise Gap
then the in-house team should be better
than the Advan its team and then at that
point you decouple and you let them go
you want to make sure that you have a
clear deadline for when you want to make
that transition and this is good for a
couple reasons one is because it sets
expectations with them they can also see
the LTV and you can talk in terms of
that let's say it's six thousand dollars
a month I'm committing to thirty six
thousand dollars all right so like
you're gonna get that for me as long as
you're not an idiot but the real real is
that your team also knows that you're
like Hey we're one month down we got to
understand this stuff in five months hey
we're two months down we've got to
understand this stuff in four months and
so it drives you towards the outcome of
getting your team up to speed faster now
you have that deadline but what if your
team's not as good as theirs by the time
the deadline comes well in my opinion
you either need to change the people or
they're not teaching you everything that
needs to happen because if they're
low-skilled people are doing better than
your team some who is a problem either
them or you let's assume that the people
are right and limit just a more complex
platform whatever I keep going until our
team matches theirs once our team match
is theirs then I drop it off we
downgraded to a Consulting agreement
just for insurance one or two months
later if we feel like we're not learning
anything on the calls that we have from
a Consulting perspective we cut it and
we do so amicably because we set that as
the expectation that's how I grew my
YouTube so now let's approach the same
concept but on a different platforms I
didn't understand Tick Tock at all I
didn't use it I wasn't on it I actually
had an agency reach out to me how about
which is not common for me to accept
that but they said listen you do no work
so from a value perspective the offer
was we you already have enough content
out there I can repurpose it and make
shorts out of it I was like okay sure if
you want to do all the work and involve
me at nothing and just make content for
me sounds good and so that's what they
did and they started getting traction
with the short videos and we're like
okay this stuff works and then for me my
director of brand actually had a super
deep history on short form content and
so normally I would have had that second
phase where I would go for that premium
agency but that individual worked at a
premium agency and so I actually bought
the Sops automatically and we were able
to massively scale our output on short
content within six or so months of
working with that original agency and
again we're on good terms with the
person in the agency if you set the
expectation up front which is I want to
learn from you and I want to be
transparent about my intentions and I
want to eventually bring this in-house
because it's my belief that my team will
be able to allocate more time to my
thing and understand my brand better and
if they had your skills they will be
able to do more output at higher quality
than you could ever do you have to make
a margin I don't I'm going to cover cost
and get five times more output this is
what I believe has married the best
parts of agency and the best part of
building an Enterprise and making a
valuable business and avoided the agency
traps so many people fall into myself
included so the first agency experience
I ever had was actually really good I
then worked with like 10 more agencies
and all of them were terrible and this
is the exact process of what happened so
reading directly from 100 million dollar
leads step one they got me excited about
all the new leads they would bring step
two I'd go through an onboarding process
that felt valuable and sometimes was
step three they assigned their best
senior rep to my account step four I saw
some results step five they moved my
senior rep to the newest customer step
six a junior rep starts managing my
account my results suffer so seven I
complained step eight the senior rep
would come back once in a while to make
me feel better step nine the results
still never got back to where they were
before and I'd eventually cancel step 10
I'd search for another agency and repeat
the cycle of insanity Step 11 for the
zillionth time start wondering why I
wasn't getting results like the first
time
so how do you decide if using the agency
is right for you first off do you have
more money or more time if you don't
have any money then you got to learn it
and it's going to take time and you know
what that's part of life usually you
master one platform you get some success
you get a little bit cash flow and then
you can more quickly pay to learn the
other ones you pay down your ignorance
tests faster if you have the money then
for me it's always worth paying on that
debt and that process is how we
approached LinkedIn how we approach
podcasts how we approach paid ads all of
them I run the same Playbook